Timofey hollowed off is one of his
team's great hopes the group of young
disabled people from eastern Ukraine and
their coach REM estados Tina are all
highly motivated many of the young
athletes were orphans or placed in
children's homes by their parents when
they were babies nao kojima stauros Tina
is like a mother to them she helps make
sure we get vocational training at the
same time we prepare for competitions
first at the national level and then for
the European Championships remaster
Astana is hoping she'll be able to take
some of her youngsters to Italy this
summer just taking part would be an
achievement for Timofey who has trouble
walking it was a major achievement that
the group can train here at all the town
of crimina lies in eastern Ukraine this
used to be the kids summer camp now it's
their refuge their hometown of luhansk
is nearby but on the other side of the
front lines it's occupied by
russian-backed rebels
yea though Steve Porter cocky I still
don't understand what this is all about
what's the reason for this war the
others on our team don't understand it
either we didn't have a bad life here
now it's nothing but problems venue the
next large town to the south has
repeatedly seen heavy fighting since the
war began in 2014 skirmishes continue
even now
when the war broke out Timofey and his
team were competing for metals in their
last major championship coach daras Tina
remembers that he'd already won a medal
there but when they tried to return home
that summer the road was blocked they
couldn't get through one door that one
yes our training ground at home in lu
han's could come under fire we no longer
had a place to train we'd brought home
five medals from European competitions
but there wasn't anyone we can tell
about our success
they soon found a new location where
they could at least trained in peace and
safety I hope we eventually get going
again and make it to the Paralympics but
they're still in the midst of a war
until recently the disabled athletes had
to walk the distance from their quarters
to the gym and back when the fighting
began in 2014 the pro-russian rebels
stole their old minibus status Tina had
to lobby the Ukrainian authorities for
months to get a new one who'd you buy
you my ordinary people help us out the
authorities don't least of all the
bureaucrats but they were determined to
carry on even in the midst of a
dangerous war zone with military
checkpoints and destruction all around
the athletes quarters have become a kind
of oasis of peace and the Olympic spirit
everyone on the team does their bit
helping out where they can Timofey is
almost always at his coaches side she
gives a tour of their new training
grounds this is our stadium now as soon
as this warm will be outside the
athletes do what they can to keep each
other's spirits up their old home in
luhansk seems so far away Timofey and
the rest of the team are still hoping
their barracks are just a temporary home
until the war between Ukrainian and
rebel forces is over yo what you know to
my dears but I really hope it ends
because I'd rather live and study in
Luhansk a metal katana chitza some wood
there are many more possibilities that
but the fighting in eastern Ukraine goes
on and the coach seems to have settled
in here with her athletes for the long
haul